hello everybody and welcome to episode
six of B and selling in free-play
RuneScape uh we're starting today's
episode at about 2.5 mil uh we're going
to try a couple new items this episode
and also some of the old tried and true
ones uh yes so let's just jump right
into it here okay so for the first item
here uh you can see in the background
we're doing the admin play legs I mean
we've done a lot but uh we just checked
that the margin was massive I mean they
bought for 29k and we sold them for
around 8K I believe uh so yeah it's like
a 20K margin right there so we're
obviously going to try these and and
yeah we'll buy I think 30 of
them and for the second item here we're
going to try the iron plate legs G again
and um for any of you wondering how I'm
putting the price in it's pretty much
random uh the graph is kind of useful
but it's pretty hard to know for sure so
we put it in for 89k and we'll game we
going to try to buy 10 of these not sure
how many of these I'm going to buy but
rather buy something for cheap than
accidentally buy it for too much and
then be stuck with them and for the
third item here we noticed that Maple
logs were down to 21 uh which is pretty
low for their average price and yes so
that's pretty good buy most likely could
go up a couple GP so we're going to buy
40K of these and um we'll leave it in
overnight and hopefully they rise a
couple GP uh but either way we should
make at least 40K on them so yeah I'll
see you guys tomorrow okay so we have
bought and sold the majority of the
items we bought uh so we managed to get
32,000 of the logs and they did rise 1
GP so we made about 70k on those the
iron plate legs we had a 10K margin on
each one uh so that's 40K there uh the
animate plate legs were still in the
process of zelling um but we will just
check the history here just to verify
everything and yeah so you can see the
admin play legs I mean we've only sold
four of the 15 and we're almost recouped
our entire by price so basically
whatever we sell the rest of them for is
just our profit all right so after
rechecking the ad play they've dropped
to about 15K but still we managed to
sell so many of them for a high price
that once we pop in 15K here uh we'll
see approximately what our profit will
so we'll made almost probably more like
180k on those that's a really good flip
there and uh We've noticed the maple
logs have gone back down to 21 coins so
we're going to try buying some more of
these because they've worked pretty well
and they are very quick to buy um so
we're going to do 60k at the 21 coin
Mark and for the last item here we're
going to try the iron plate legs again
uh we did get a 10K margin but I thought
we could get something a bit higher so
we're going to try to buy them for the
89k Mark again and we'll put in 10 and
just hopefully get more than one this
time okay so we have sold everything and
uh we did some really good flips this
time you can see the iron PL legs uh we
got 55k on those I wish we had bought
them for a bit of a higher price because
we may have actually gotten more than
one this time uh whereas we've only ever
gotten one so oh well but we still got
55k on just the one item so that's
really good uh the maple logs did rise
we had a 3 GP margin in that which is
great so we had about 180k we made on
that one and uh the admin plate legs
that's pretty much pure Profit just from
the other flip from a couple times ago
uh so yeah we're doing pretty good we're
almost at 3 mil Mark already okay so we
notic the logs we're at 21 again so I
promise you we will mix this up
eventually but there's just no reason
not to do this so we'll buy 100K at the
21 coin Mark all right so surprise doing
the iron play legs again I know we've
done this a bunch but we're going to try
buying them at 99k this time and we're
just going to buy five because you know
we never get more than one anyway so
what's the point uh so I didn't realize
till afterwards i' had done essentially
the same flip like three times in a row
so I apologize for that um we'll try to
mix it up going forward here but uh it
is working so this can't complain too
much uh so we'll do adamant play legs
again they had like a seven or eight
margin or 8K margin on them and uh yeah
we'll try 30 again and I promise next
time we'll do something
different okay so that was pretty much a
failure so uh the maple logs didn't buy
all so we instead did these big bones
just to give them a try uh they worked
pretty well but it was a very low margin
overall like we made 50k which isn't so
bad and it didn't take too long to flip
them but I'm not sure if I do them again
and yeah so the maple logs I only got 14
of them so I just abandon that uh same
with the iron plate legs couldn't buy
any of them I guess the price is rising
and the ad play legs I mean we got a few
but I'm just going to cancel these out
and we're going to try something
different okay so we're going to start
off by dumping the Adam and plate legs
in here for 15K almost so we'll make
still probably 20 30k on those so it's
not the end of the world seem to recall
somebody saying that they weren't going
to do any of the same items
again so yeah sorry about that but I I
literally looked for half an hour for a
better item and it just I'm not going to
do a worse item just for the sake of
variety
um so we're going to try these again
we're going to put a massive amount in
so we're going to do 100K and I mean we
can make an easy 200k here so there's
really no point not to okay so and
lastly here uh we are just checking a
couple items here you can check my
history here I think we're going to go
with this mythal kite Shield you can see
it has about 13k margin on it but we
tried some other items as well uh but
not as good so we're going to go with
the mythal kite Shield this time and
we'll put an offer in for 12,000 and
we're going to buy uh 30 of them all
right so I'll check back in a minute
okay so we've sold and bought a lot of
things since last clip uh so the adant
pl legs we totally dumped off so that's
good I can't remember how much we made
on those but probably 20 30k uh the
admin kite Shield we actually bought all
30 of them for
11,500 uh so we're slowly selling them
off we sold uh four of them I think for
almost 25,000 so that's really good uh
that's about 50k on those right there
plus we have to sell off the rest of
them I think the margin's dropped though
um that's that's okay and uh the maple
logs we got about 75k of them for 21
coins each so hopefully we can get a two
or three GP margin on those uh we'll
have to check them again okay so we're
going to start off by just selling the
maple logs uh cuz those are kind of the
most straightforward uh so the the
margin's still 3 GP so that's really
good so we should hopefully make uh well
75 time three should get close to 200k
off these that's pretty good flip uh
really quick to buy and sell as
well okay so next we're going to do the
kite Shield uh the margin dropped about
15K you can see right there uh so that's
not the greatest but still not too bad
we'll get 3 or 4K per items still and
yes we'll put them in for about 15K and
leave those in for a while and lastly
here we're going to actually try a
gilded piece of armor so it's the first
time we're trying this I the price is
going to be pretty hard to determine I
mean you can see the graph here uh but
I'm not really sure exactly so we're
going to put in a a lower Buy offer and
just hope we get it
uh cuz I feel like we have the potential
to make maybe 100K on this item so we're
going to try 770 and we'll just leave
that in while the rest of these things
sell okay a clip got lost again so I'll
just explain quickly what happened the
guilded play B we just didn't get it all
didn't buy that uh the maple logs we
sold for 2 GP margin as opposed to three
so we got 150k from that and uh the
mythal kite shields in total off all
that we made 150k so that's still pretty
good and you can see on the screen we're
just buying a couple new items here we
got some team capes going in uh mythal
arrows had about two three GP margin on
those so we're going to try that and the
party hats had about a five or sixk
margin on those uh so we'll just kind of
quickly you can just kind of see right
on screen there no point kind of going
too in depth there and yeah so we're
going to try to buy these all and I'll
come back when some of them are
bought okay so we have nearly sold
everything uh everything except for the
mithil arrows so I think we're going to
call it the end of the episode episode
uh so we'll just do a tally up of all
the money we made so far in this episode
and what our cash Jack will be looking
like we managed to uh sell almost 8,000
of the mial arrows you can see right
here that's about 10 GP on each one so
that's almost 80k we made on the arrows
at the team capes we got about
75k and the party hats we actually got
about
125k so that's really good that final
flip I mean we made almost see probably
like 300K so that's really good uh if we
take into account the mythal arrows that
are in the process of selling we should
be between 3.5 mil and 3.6 mil so either
way we've made some serious progress
over a m this episode and I think we've
decided we're going to stop at 5 mil and
then we're going to buy a bond for
membership so yeah thanks for uh tuning
in guys if you enjoyed just hit that
subscribe button and I will see you guys
next time
[Music]